[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
as against amber heard we the jury award
compensatory damages in the amount of 10
million dollars for the first time since
the verdicts were read defendant amber
heard speaks out and did miss redlich
tell you why she did not call 9-1-1
she just says she couldn't find her
phone due to all the blood and stuff on
the floor child protective services
investigators take the stand as a
florida woman is tried for the murder of
her husband plus hear from both sides as
convicted killer alan wade faces the
death penalty some evil acts
can only
be sufficiently punished
and while some crimes do deserve the
death penalty
some defendants do not
and later a michigan police officer is
charged in the death of patrick leola
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer it's been
nearly two weeks since jurors reached
their verdicts in the johnny depp versus
amber heard trial for the first time
since then we're hearing from defendant
amber heard
millions of viewers watch the verdict
handed down right here on law and crime
network and the gavital gavel coverage
of the trial before that actor depp
sued ex-wife amber heard for 50 million
dollars arguing heard defamed him in her
2018 washington post op-ed about
domestic abuse hurt fired back with a
hundred million dollar counter suit
doubling down on her abuse claims after
weeks of testimony including from both
depp and heard the jury awarded depp 10
million dollars in compensatory damages
and 5 million in punitive damages heard
also won part of her counter suit when
she was awarded 2 million in
compensatory damages and nothing for
punitive damages over comments made by
depp's attorney adam waltman for the
first time since the verdict heard sat
down with nbc news's savannah guthrie
for an exclusive interview heard told
guthrie she does not blame the jurors
for the verdict
i don't care what one thinks about me
or what judgments you want to make about
what happened in the privacy of my own
home and my marriage behind closed doors
i don't presume the average person
should know those things and so i don't
take it personally but even somebody who
is
sure
i'm deserving
of
all this hate in vitriol
even if you think
that i'm lying you still couldn't look
me in the eye and tell me that you think
on social media there's been a fair
representation you cannot tell me
that you think that this has been fair
of course we also touched on what
happened in court and what the jury
decided
there's no polite way to say it
the jury
looked at the evidence you presented
they listened to your testimony and they
did not believe you
they thought you were lying
how could
i put it this way
how could they
make a judgment how could they not come
to that conclusion they had sat
in those seats
and heard through over three weeks
of non-stop relentless testimony
from paid
employees
and towards the end of the trial randos
as i say
so you don't blame the jury i don't
blame them it wasn't i i don't blame
them i actually understand he's a
beloved character
and people feel they know him he's a
fantastic actor their job is to not be
dazzled by that
their job is to look at the facts and
the evidence
and they did not believe
your testimony or your evidence
and
again
how could they after listening to three
and a half weeks of testimony about how
i was a nun credible person
not to believe a word that came out of
my mouth
we're going to have more of our
exclusive interview with amber heard
first on today tomorrow and wednesday
morning it's a wide ranging sit down and
then we'll have the conversation on a
special date line this friday night hour
long 8 7 central looking forward to that
the interview will air on nbc news today
tuesday june 14th and wednesday june
15th after that more on the sit-down
interview will air on friday june 17th
on 8 pm eastern
on dateline
joining us today is co-host terry austin
and trial attorney janine atian
janine
the trial is done amber heard owes debt
what 10.35 million dollars could herd be
doing these interviews
just as a way to win in the court of
public opinion because she lost at trial
well absolutely and you know she comes
across much more likable during this
interview than she did when she was
testifying on the stand the other thing
that i think is important is that you
know johnny depp's attorneys have
alluded to the fact that he may not
enforce this judgment and so maybe she's
trying to appeal to him she uses certain
words like rando um she talks about how
he's a fantastic actor she could be
being facetious or she could be kind of
like throwing out an olive branch so i
think that she could be trying to win in
the in the public opinion but also she
could be trying to get away from this
judgment
yeah we'll see how that plays out
especially as well one or both of their
careers has got to either be taking off
or stopping at this point but terry you
watch the trial gap it'll gather more
than probably anyone else and you've
been on team debt pretty firmly for a
while your reaction to herds interview
you know i did begin with an open mind
but i've got to say brian just listening
to all of her testimony you have to come
to the conclusion that she's lying she
lied about why she wrote that article
she lied about the fact that it was
about him and she even admitted that
later on the stand she said that she had
all these injuries those turned out to
be lies she lied about sending the video
to tmz
so and you know she also lied about the
7 million divorce settlement that she
gave it to charity so i think she's
trying to blame someone she's not taking
responsibility and while she's not
blaming the jury she is saying look he
had all of this evidence paid people who
came in so i think it's a public
relations stunt and i think she's trying
to absolve herself of any responsibility
yeah she's basically saying that all of
johnny depp's witnesses perjured
themselves that they're paid and they
lied which is an interesting argument
let's see if there's a lawsuit that
follows those accusations though thank
you both
still ahead on law and crime daily
opening statements are presented in the
penalty phase of convicted killer alan
wade but first a third story enters the
narrative as accused husband killer
danielle redlich stands trial
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
testimony continued into day three
monday in the florida trial of danielle
redlich a woman accused of stabbing her
husband to death bradley claims she
killed her husband michael redlich in
self-defense when she stabbed him in
their winter park home in 2019 the two
had been married for nearly 20 years and
had two children together danielle's
defense attorney said their relationship
had a history of abuse and cheating and
the couple had even filed for divorce by
the time of michael's death in january
2019. 9-1-1 calls reveal danielle
initially told dispatchers that michael
had stabbed himself and had held a heart
attack investigators say danielle waited
several hours to call for help and cell
phone records show she spent time on
dating apps before calling 9-1-1
danielle is charged with second-degree
murder and evidence tampering and could
spend life in prison if convicted on
monday child protective services
investigator taylin tucker took the
stand she was assigned to the case the
day after michael was killed she told
the jury about the different story
danielle told about what happened the
night michael died
did she
share with you what she saw michael do
with the knife next
um she just stated that he ended up
taking it like taken out of her hand and
then kind of making like a stabbing
motion towards himself
did she stay in the room or go anywhere
else she
she left and went to the bathroom what
did she say happens next after things
went quiet
she just opened up the bathroom door and
then went out went out like she just saw
a trail of blood from
the bathroom to the living room and she
just followed the trail of blood to the
living room what did miss redlich say
that she did when she saw she followed
that trail of love
she went to see if like he was breathing
did she do anything to try to help him
yes what did she say she did tried to do
like cpr
did miss redlich tell you why she did
not call 9-1-1 she just says she
couldn't find her phone due to all the
blood and stuff on the floor
all right terry based on this testimony
is daniel redlich's story credible and
moreover will the jurors believe it
her story is not credible brian and i
don't think the jury is buying it listen
we have multiple versions of this first
she tells 9-1-1 he had a heart attack
and then he stabbed himself and then she
says he was there with the knife she saw
the knife and then he made these motions
she went to the bathroom then there's
another version of that story where
she's in the shower and you know she
comes out and he's stabbed to death so i
think the jury knows that she did it and
now she's claiming self-defense so
they're going to have to figure out what
really happened based on all of this
evidence and the different stories that
the witnesses are telling and they're
going to realize that you know she just
made up stories as she went along
yeah different stories and janine based
on the opening and how the defense are
arguing the case it seems to me at least
that redlick has to take the stand to
explain the changing stories or
self-defense how do you think she'll
survive on cross-examination
well it's going to remain to be seen but
she absolutely absolutely has to take
the stand because she's had all of these
differing stories she's lied time and
time again but the other thing is her
lies are blatant you know she calls
9-1-1 when she finally does and she says
he had a heart attack they're going to
come to a house filled with blood so the
idea that these are such uh incredible
lies you know it may be that when she
gets on the stand and she explains you
remember this was her stepfather um
there's a history of a volatile
relationship the defense opening says
that he was authoritative with her she
may be able to you know show that she
lied because she was scared and then
remember her daughter testified today we
didn't get to see it but she said her
father was drinking that they fought a
lot she did say her mother was
oftentimes the instigator but again once
this woman gets on the stand we'll have
a better understanding and until she
does we don't know absolutely we'll see
how that plays out but we'll definitely
be watching here gavin will gavel for
that testimony if and as i think when
she takes a stand
and switching coast to california as
attorneys prepared to present opening
statements in the eric holder trial in
los angeles tuesday holter is a man
accused of killing rapper nipsey hussell
after three years of delays defendant
eric holder is facing a jury for the
first time on charges of first-degree
murder attempted murder and assault with
a deadly weapon holder was arrested in
april 2019 less than a week after he
allegedly shot and killed nipsey hussell
in front of the rapper's marathon
clothing store police say a dispute
broke out between the two men when
hustle accused holder of being a snitch
investigators say holder left the store
and then returned with two firearms a
medical examiner found hustle was shot
at least 10 times with the bullets
piercing his lungs and severing his
spinal cord the judge has ruled there
will be limited media coverage allowed
as witness testimony will not be
broadcast opening statements are
expected to be presented tuesday holder
faces life in prison if he's convicted
coming up on law and crime daily a
police officer is charged in the death
of patrick leola
plus
dear opening statements from both sides
as a florida jury weighs a death penalty
sentence against alan wade
[Music]
welcome back an abrupt pause in the
penalty phase in the re-sentencing trial
of alan wade is book-ended with opening
statements from the prosecution and
defense the sentencing phase is now in a
way for alan wade who was previously
convicted in the deaths of reggie and
carol sumner wade along with michael
james jackson tiffany cole and bruce
nixon were convicted more than a decade
ago for their involvement in the murder
prosecutors argued at the defendant's
trials that the four dug a hole in a
remote wooded spot in georgia before
kidnapping the summoners the group stole
from the couple's home then forced them
into the trunk of their own car they
later forced the couple to share their
bank account information before burying
them alive wade in jackson will be
re-sentenced separately after a change
in florida law which requires a
unanimous jury decision for the death
penalty last thursday prosecutors
presented opening statements
the state of florida is presenting this
case to each and every one of you
because some evil acts
are just too great
to tell
some evil acts
can only
be sufficiently punished
by the ultimate punishment
of death
in these in this trial
this week and next
each and every one of you
will bear witness
to the heinous
atrocious
and cruel evil acts
that human beings are capable
after opening statements the state
called wade's co-defendant bruce nixon
while nixon was expected to testify on
behalf of prosecution he testified he
wanted to quote tell the truth when
called nixon who originally took the
plea deal and did not receive the death
penalty could now face that sentence
after violating turns of the original
plea deal when the judge ruled that both
sides could not question nixon defense
attorneys called for the judge to recuse
himself saying he inserted himself into
the trial after the very confrontational
moment defense attorneys threatened to
call nixon as their witness after that
court took a recess until monday on
monday nixon returned to court with an
attorney and plead the fifth later that
day the state rested its case and
defense attorneys presented their
opening statement
he will spend the rest of his days in a
concrete cage and he will be carried out
of the department of corrections in a
concrete box
he will leave in a casket
the only question that remains now is
whether he dies of natural causes
or whether it's a lethal injection
at the end of this trial you're going to
vote on whether a man
a human being
alan lindell waited
whether he lives
or whether he dies
and while some crimes do deserve the
death penalty
some defendants do not
this is one decision that you will live
with for the rest of your lives and i'm
going to to suggest to you that you will
never ever regret
choosing life
all right terry so nixon pleased the
fifth in wade's resentencing after an
absolute breakdown the first time but
you can't unring that bell that the jury
heard it so how do you think it will
affect them in their decision making
well you know i think you're absolutely
right brian once a jury hears something
it is very hard to disregard and judge
weatherby said listen don't draw any
conclusions disregard the testimony but
that's almost impossible the jury is
going to be wondering
what was he thinking what was he going
to say what was the truth is the truth
what he said before now the good news is
the judge did allow the prosecution to
read into the record his former
testimony so he did testify in the
record about the fact that alan wade was
not forced to commit this crime but
we'll see what the jury is thinking
because it could be a little bit
confusing to them to hear these you know
conflicting stories from this individual
yeah now janine
how was the defense opening considering
potentially their strongest witness pled
the fifth and how will that change your
arguments going further
i actually don't think it's going to
because again you know the prosecution
was able to read into um the test of
reading to evidence um
nixon's testimony and here's the thing
despite what happened it was an absolute
circus he testified that you know
they've gotten through the duct tape in
the trunk of the car they were hugging
it's just a really really
heinous situation and when um the
defense says you know some crimes
deserve the death penalty but some
defendants do not i really don't know
how you can reconcile what he did with
that statement i i just don't see it and
i think the jury is not going to see it
i would tend to agree there as well
we'll see what the jury decides in this
re-sentencing of allen wade again
florida changes their their laws when it
comes to the death penalty and that's
why we're doing this again
when we come back a michigan officer is
charged in the death of patrick leona
still ahead what plea he entered
[Music]
welcome back two months after 26 year
old black man patrick leola was shot and
killed during a traffic stop the grand
rapids michigan officer who pulled him
over is charged with murder
officer christopher schuh is now charged
with second-degree murder the officer
pulled leola over the morning of april
4th for an unregistered license plate
when leola got out of the car he and the
officer struggled and fought across
several front lawns leola was shot in
the back of the head which was caught on
camera the officer was placed on
administrative leave pending the
investigation and stripped of his police
powers sure pleaded not guilty on friday
and was released on a hundred thousand
dollars bond with conditions prominent
civil rights attorney ben crump is
representing leola's family
all right gene christopher shu's lawyer
said the shooting was justified but he
was on top of leola and shot him in the
back of the head even if he had his
taser could that still be justified
well here's the thing i'm waiting to see
what evidence this attorney can put in
okay because he talks about it was fired
twice and it could be in a certain kind
of mode again he was shot in the back of
the head the officer was on top of him
and it's a tragedy you know mr leo was
26 years old but again you know he did
um
resist arrest he did fight he did grab
the taser so it's really going to be
about what evidence they can put forth
to show that this police officer really
felt that they were in danger for their
life and that they had to use deadly
force right yeah plenty of video you can
see there from close up and from a
distance terry sure's attorney said he
did everything according to department
policy so it makes me think is this
about a bad cop or bad police policy
well let me tell you something i have
read the grand rapids police department
use of force policy this police officer
absolutely positively did not follow
that policy basically you're supposed to
de-escalate and you use the level of
force based on the level of resistance
and so if it's a pass of resistance or
even if it's active and he runs away he
did not have to respond the way he did
and so one of the things that these
police officers have to be trained to do
is not to escalate the situation he
could have let him go he had the car
there was no reason to chase him down
there was no reason to take out that
taser and have it be in a position where
it could be taken from you and this is
what the policy states it says all of
these things you don't have to use
deadly force you don't have to get
yourself in that type of position so i
think this is a situation where the
police officer could have done other
things he could have given verbal
directions he could have used physical
control without using that taser but at
the end of the day he put himself in
that position and it could very well be
he had to use deadly force at that point
but he didn't follow the policy all
right we're going to find out a lot more
about this case and the grand rapids
police department's use of force policy
thank you both and thank you for joining
us here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you